♪ ♪
>> Greg: DEMOCRATS IN THE
MEDIA RAMPING UP CALLS TO BAN
GUNS AFTER THE MASSACRE IN
HIGHLAND PARK, VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS LEADING THE CHARGE WHILE
VISITING THE AREA OF HER CALLING
FOR AN ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN, BUT
IT WOULD NOT BE A SPEECH WITHOUT
SOME OF HER SIGNATURE WORD
LINGUINE.
>> WE WILL DEAL WITH WHAT WE
NEED TO DEAL WITH WITH IN TERMS
OF AS WE MOVE FORWARD ALL THE
GRAIN THAT WE HAVE TO BE SMARTER
AS A COUNTRY IN TERMS OF ACCESS
TO WHAT AND PARTICULAR ASSAULT
WEAPONS AND WE HAVE TO TAKE THIS
STUFF SERIOUSLY.
AS SERIOUSLY AS YOU ARE, BECAUSE
YOU HAVE BEEN FORCED TO HAVE TO
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
>> CONGRESS NEEDS TO HAVE THE
COURAGE TO ACT AND RENEW THE
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN.
>> Greg: THE MEDIA IS BLAMING
THE VIOLENCE ON THE CONSTITUTION
BECAUSE IT IS ACTUALLY RACIST.
>> 100% US, AND BECAUSE WE ARE
ESSENTIALLY TO A DOCUMENT THAT
WAS WRITTEN MORE THAN 230 YEARS
AGO BY A TINY GROUP OF WHITE
SLAVE-OWNING MAN, YOU NOW?
AND WE CANNOT BREAK OUT OF THE
ABUNDANCE THAT WE HAVE PUT ON
OURSELVES FEELING LIKE WE HAVE
TO EVERYTHING IS DECIDED IN
REFERENCE TO THIS ANCIENT
DOCUMENT WHICH IS JUST NOT
SERVING US WELL.
>> Greg: TINY, WAY TOO BESIDES
THIS, AS A MEDIOCRE FOCUS IS ON
ONE ACT OF VIOLENCE THEY ARE
IGNORING OTHER CRIME, AND 250
PEOPLE SHOT AND KILLED OVER THE
JULY 4TH WEEKEND IN CITIES,
JESSICA, THIS IS NOW I BELIEVE
THAT THIRD OR FOURTH CRISIS THEY
ABSENT THE VICE PRESIDENT TWO.
IS IT CLEAR TO YOU AS IT IS
CLEAR TO ME THAT THIS IS A
PERFORMATIVE POLITICAL SIGNAL
THERE AS SHE DOES NOT BREAK
ANYTHING AND COMES BACK, BECAUSE
SHE HAS NOT SOLVED A SINGLE
PROBLEM.
>> Jessica: IT IS A
COMMUNICATION JOB VERSUS SOLVING
WHAT IS GOING ON AT THE BORDER
OR THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE ISSUE
ARE VERY DIFFERENT THINGS, I
ACTUALLY THOUGHT SHE DID A
GOOD JOB TALKING ABOUT THE ROE
DECISION, IT IS IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU HAVE THE FIRST FEMALE
VICE PRESIDENT TO TALK ABOUT A
DECISION THAT AFFECTS WOMEN ALL
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND LINGUINE
OR WHATEVER WE ARE CALLING IT, I
WAS NOT THAT CAUGHT OFF IN IT,
BUT THE SUBSTANCE WHICH WAS THAT
RENEWING THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN
WHICH BROUGHT DOWN 53 DEATHS OF
MASS SHOOTINGS DOWN BY 43% OVER
THE 10-YEAR PERIOD AND THEN 243%
SPIKE AFTER IT IS A GOOD IDEA.
AND IT TO YOUR POINT SANDRA HE
REALLY CAPTURED THE MOOD AND HOW
PEOPLE ARE FEELING ABOUT THIS
THAT THEY WANT MORE, AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS AN
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN IN ILLINOIS,
BUT A FEDERAL ONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T WAKE UP ON ANY
GIVEN DAY ON WHETHER IT IS
FOURTH OF JULY OR ANOTHER
HOLIDAY OR JUST YOUR AVERAGE
TUESDAY AND SEE MORE PEOPLE
NEEDLESSLY SLAUGHTERED WITH
WEAPONS THAT THERE IS NO GOOD
REASON THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS KID IN
PARTICULAR I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT
HIS FATHER SIGNED OFF ON THIS TO
HELP THEM GET IT AND THERE WERE
RED FLAGS ALL OVER THE PLACE,
BUT WE CAN STOP SOME OF THESE
SHOOTINGS BY MAKING THIS A
FEDERAL POLICY AGAIN.
>> Sandra: AND RED FLAG LAWS
THAT CLEARLY DID NOT WORK.
>> Greg: I WAS GOING TO SAY
THERE WERE SO MANY RED FLAGS,
WHO DROPPED THE BALL?
>> Judge Jeanine: I THOUGHT IT
WAS INTERESTING YESTERDAY WITH
THE PRESS CONFERENCE WHERE I
THINK IT WAS THE DEPUTY SHERIFF
SAID, WELL, THERE IS NOTHING WE
COULD HAVE DONE BECAUSE WE DID
NOT HAVE ANYONE TO SIGN A
COMPLAINT I AND ABOUT 50
PROSECUTORS I KNOW WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THAT TOO.
IF YOU GO INTO A HOME AND THERE
ARE 17 KNIVES AND ONE SWORD AND
ONE DAGGER IN THE INDIVIDUAL HAD
TRIED TO KILL HIMSELF A FEW
MONTHS EARLIER, YOU DON'T TAKE
THE KNIVES AND THEN SAY, GEE,
YOU KNOW, WE ARE GOING TO LEAVE
HIM HERE.
WE ARTY KNOW HE IS SUICIDAL, MAY
HAVE BEEN HOMICIDAL WITH ALL OF
THESE KNIVES, THEY DID NOT GIVE
THE INFORMATION TO THE STATE
POLICE AND THEN WHEN HE TRIED TO
COMMIT SUICIDE AND THEY SAY THAT
THEY DID GET THE INFORMATION OF
THE KNIVES TO THE STATE POLICE.
THEY COULD'VE PROSECUTED THAT
KID EARLY ON OR THEY COULD'VE
GOTTEN HIM THE MENTAL HEALTH HE
NEEDED.
HIS FATHER AS CULPABLE.
HIS FATHER SAID HE SPONSORED HIM
IN ORDER FOR HIM TO GET A GUN.
IN ORDER FOR HIM TO SIGN OFF FOR
THAT KID TO BUY A GUN UNDER THE
AGE OF 21, HE HAD TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS KID'S
MENTAL HEALTH, AND EVERYONE KNEW
ABOUT THIS --
LIVING WITH A KID, HE TRIED TO
COMMIT SUICIDE.
HE IS ALONE OR IN ISOLATED
COMING OF THE KIND OF MUSIC HE
IS SINGING, AND OTHER CRAZY
STUFF THAT HE IS DRAWING.
AND THAT'S WHEN I AM LOOKING AT
A SOCIAL MEDIA, SO I THINK THAT
THE PARENTS ARE IN DEEP LEGAL
TROUBLE AS WELL THEY SHOULD
BE, AND I THINK THAT THE POLICE
HAVE TO STOP SAYING, THERE'S
NOTHING WE COULD HAVE DONE.
WE DID NOT HAVE ANYONE TO SIGN A
COMPLAINT.
BOLOGNA, I WOULD'VE FILED A
CHARGE IN THAT CASE AND A
SECOND.
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES,
FAMILY MEMBERS DON'T LIKE TO
FILE A COMPLAINT, YOU BRING THE
CASE IN THE NAME OF THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF ILLINOIS AND
WHEREVER IT FALLS OUT AT THE END
IS WHERE IT ENDS UP, BUT IN THE
MEANTIME YOU GET THE KID IN THE
SYSTEM, YOU GET A RECORD ON
THEM, AND YOU TRACK HIM FROM
THAT POINT.
>> Greg: EVERYONE OF THESE
CASES AND THEY JUST KEEP COMING,
THEY ALWAYS TURN OUT TO SOUND
THE SAME, BUT THEN YOU LOOK INTO
IT AND THERE IS ALWAYS ONE KEY
CHARACTERISTIC THAT DEFINES WHY
IT MIGHT'VE HAPPENED AND THE
JUDGE BRINGS UP THE FATHER,
SIGNING THE WARRANT, THAT IS
LIKE --
THAT IS WHAT LED TO THIS.
HOW CAN HE BE CHARGED?
>> Sandra: IT THAT GOES TO THE
RED FLAG LAWS, AT THE GUN
DEBATE.
THEY FAILED IN THIS CASE, SO
LOCAL POLICE NEVER LET THE STATE
POLICE KNOW THAT THIS HAPPENED.
WAS NOT SUICIDAL WHEN THEY FOUND
THOSE WEAPONS THAT WERE NOT GUNS
IN THE HOME, KNIVES AND OTHER
THINGS, HE ACTUALLY DID SAY THAT
HE THREATENED TO KILL EVERYONE
IN HIS FAMILY.
THAT IS IN THE LOCAL POLICE
REPORTS.
THAT WAS BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION OF LOCAL POLICE,
WITHOUT BEING REPORTED AS THE
JUDGES POINTING OUT THEY CAN'T
DO ANYTHING TO STOP THAT FO I.D.
CARD FROM GETTING IN THE HANDS
OF SOMEBODY WHO CLEARLY HAD
INTENT TO KILL.
I JUST SAY ONE THING, WHEN IT
COMES TO KAMALA HARRIS AND
JESSICA, TEAR POINT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT ABORTION AND THE
FOCUS ON THAT AND SOMETHING THAT
EVERY WOMAN IN THIS COUNTRY
CARES ABOUT, EVERY WOMAN IN THIS
COUNTRY ALSO CARES ABOUT THEIR
SAFETY AND YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING AROUND THIS COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW AND IT IS TERRIFYING.
WHERE IS KAMALA HARRIS IN THE
CITY OF CHICAGO 68 PEOPLE SHOT
OVER THE THE FOURTH OF JULY
WEEKEND, TEN PEOPLE KILLED,
NEW YORK CITY, 21 SHOT, THREE
KILLED.
I GOT AN UPDATE IN MY PHONE, THE
LAST 24 HOURS SINCE IT ENDED IN
NEW YORK CITY, NINE MORE SHOTS,
TWO KILLED IN THE CITY, WHY NOT
STAND HERE AND PROMISED TO DO
MORE, PROMISED TO END THE
VILIFICATION OF THE POLICE AND
AMP UP SAFETY AND ARE STREETS,
BECAUSE YOU CAN SAY THAT THAT
WILL BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ELECTION ISSUES, NOVEMBER.
>> Jessica: 100%.
>> Jesse: ON THE PARENTS
ARRESTED AND THE FATHER CAME
BACK AND SAID THOSE WERE MIND
KNIVES, DAGGERS, AND SWORDS.
IT'S NEGLIGENCE, HE IS AN
ACCESSORY, IT'S LIKE AIDING AND
ABETTING THE ENEMY, HOUSING AND
SHELTERING AND FEEDING A
DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
SO THAT WILL WAKE PARENTS UP IF
YOU HIT THEM WITH A CHARGE LIKE
THAT.
WE HAD A CASE ON "THE FACTOR"
WHERE THIS SEX OFFENDER
KIDNAPPED TO THE YOUNG CHILD,
REPEATEDLY RAPED HER, THERE WERE
THREE OTHER ADULTS IN THAT CHILD
WHILE -- TRAILER WHILE THIS
CHILD IS BEING ASSAULTED AND THE
D.A. DID NOT GIVE THEM
ACCESSORY, YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO CHARGE THESE PEOPLE, BECAUSE
YOU DO NOT NOT KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON.
HE DOES NOT LIVE IN A MANSION.
LET'S WANDER OVER TO THE SON'S
WING AND KNOCK ON HIS DOOR.
THESE ARE SMALL HOMES, YOU KNOW
WHAT IS GOING ON.
IN TERMS OF THE JOY REID
SITUATION, THE DAY AFTER
JULY 4TH YOU INVITE OUR
PROFESSOR TO SLANDER THE
FOUNDERS AND BESMIRCH THE
CONSTITUTION, YOU GUYS, A
LIBERAL ADVICE FOR JOY, LAST
NIGHT I HAD A MERMAID ON THE
SHOW, SHE HAD US IN AND WAS
HIDDEN FROM A BABBLING BROOK
AND --
PEOPLE WOULD RATHER SEE THAT
THEN A SNOBBY PROFESSOR, SO I
SUGGEST IT MAY BE BOOK SOMEONE
LIKE THAT INSTEAD.
>> Greg: I LOVE THAT YOU ARE A
PRO MERMAID, THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
REPRESENTATION IN CABLE NEWS.
>> Jesse: DOES THAT SURPRISE
YOU?
I'M MORE OPEN-MINDED THAN YOU
THINK.
IT'S BEFORE